daher muss man sehr achten auch
sicherheit wie steiger arbeiten muss ich
mal einen schnellen bei gondel muss ich
mal sicherheitsgurt eintragen um einen
bauleiter arbeiten muss immer einer
unten immer festhalten damit diejenigen
nicht um gibt wenn man mit schnee arbeit
muss man aufpassen dass man die
dosierung wichtig hat dass die böden
nicht kaputt gehen und auch seine eigene
sicherheit das heißt man muss handschuhe
tragen und eine brille
sie wissen gut sein im umgang mit kunden
dass manche objekte sind halt auch dass
die kunden vor ort sind sie müssen
freundlich sein
sie müssen auf die kunden eingehen
können sie müssen wenn der kunde
irgendwie problem zu ihnen kommt eine
lösung haben sollten sie haben aber
dafür sind wir dann halt eben darum das
soll auch bei zu bringen das schönste
als gebäudereiniger ist dass man viel
rumkommt dass man viele nette
arbeitskollegen hat und dass man immer
was lernt was waren noch nicht wusste
also der job ist nicht monoton habe ich
gerne ausbildungen machen sondern da
habe ich mich angestrengt gesammelt in
20 jahren
wir beschäftigen halt mitarbeiter die
keine erfahrung haben in der
gebäudereinigung die werden von uns
anhalt eingewiesen an gelernt dass man
ihn halt das optimum mitgeben kann wie
alt noch einige auszuführen ist bei uns
kann man auch eine ausbildung starten
zum gebäudereiniger
die ausbildung dauert drei jahre und
danach hat man halt irgendwie
möglichkeit als bereichsleiter zum
beispiel bruder halt ja selber heute
irgendwelche häuser zu leiten oder
bestenfalls halt auch die menschen sogar
meister zu machen und den weiteren
schritt in die selbständigkeit ein guter
gebäudereiniger muss schnell und
gründlich arbeiten meiner job mache ich
alles gern an die macht mir spaß